we have just achieved a deal which
strengthens Britain special status in
the European Union it is a legally
binding and irreversible decision by all
28 readers the supplement addresses all
of Prime Minister Cameron's concerns
without compromising our fundamental
values if Europe is to be saved from
infinite misery as Churchill said and
indeed from final doom there must be
this act of faith in the European family
I deeply believe that the united kingdom
needs Europe and Europe needs the United
Kingdom to break the link now would be
totally against our mutual interest we
have done all we could not to let that
happen but the final decision is in the
hands of the British people let me
finish by saying I love written and I
loved wrath of thank you today all 28
member states have signed up to concrete
reforms in each of the four areas that I
set out I believe that this is enough
for me to recommend that the United
Kingdom remain in the European Union
having the best of both worlds